hello everyone and welcome back to some
more rapid action from the round two of
the ftx crypto cup it's hans mcneeman
versus magnus cross and in the previous
round uh neiman completely destroyed
magnus with the black pieces and now
magnus needs to win to bounce back into
the match now he has the black pieces
and uh we are getting treated to another
uh french defense we already checked out
his french defense game against
anishigiri uh it was um
very very enjoyable uh to watch if you
guys have seen it if you haven't it's uh
like not the previous video but the one
before that that i've uploaded do check
it out uh but here now we have a very
very different variation so neiman has
the white pieces can he continue his
lead or will magnus be able to bounce
back we have e4 by neiman ponte e6
magnus again goes for the french defense
d for d5 and now knight to d2 uh we have
the taj variation of the french pawn to
c5 the open way to challenge this knight
g to f3 and now a trade uh on d4c
captures knight captures and magnus goes
for the trade knight c6 we have bishop
the b5 pinning uh the the knight here
and the bishop to d7 now just uh well
now the knight can move so we have a
trade on c6 but a knight captures pawn
captures and the bishop back to d3 and
here bishop to d6 so this is all been
played before nothing new here uh queen
to e2 and now knight to e7 preparing the
castle
uh e5 by neman attacking the the bishop
here bishop to c7 and we have castles by
neman and now there is a game uh where
castles was played also queen to b8 is a
known move uh even um uh knights to g6
is a known move but the move magnus
plays has never been played before it is
pawn to c5 it is a standard way of of uh
treating such positions
it's kind of a uh maybe wasting a tempo
but
it definitely makes sense to grab full
control
over the center here so it is as of
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game let's see how niemann challenges
this of course he doesn't like this so
he plays c4 he wants to challenge the
center and now bishop the
c6 by magnus you don't want to push d4
right away it seems like you're grabbing
a lot of space you're creating a pass
pawn
but then you give a white full control
over uh this diagonal the knight just
gains access to d4 square it's uh
and not something you want you want to
do so here bishop to c 6 by magnus
knight to f3 and now d captures and c4
with bishop captures and finally magnus
castles with bishop to e3 putting
pressure on the uh sorry about that on
the c5 pawn and now magnus plays bishop
captures on f3 and this is one of those
uh moves that only a really really
strong player can play uh giving up your
beautiful bishop like this for this
knight but it is uh for a good reason
bishop characters on f3 queen captures
we have bishop captures an e5 and the
bishop captures on c5 it seems like you
didn't really achieve all that much as
neiman also grabbed the pawn here but
now comes queen to c7 attacking the
bishop here and putting pressure on the
h2 pawn so here bishop captures an e7 uh
grabbing uh
the piece not allowing the bishop to
capture an h2 because then your queen
will be stuck guarding that bishop so
queen captures an e7 and now queen to e2
and now magnus plays queen back to c7 so
putting even more pressure on the bishop
but still attacking that h2 pawn so
neiman has to waste the move to play g3
and that's the whole point of magnus
giving up that light square bishop and
now comes bishop captures on b2 and this
is how magnus wins the pawn so it was
not uh
not not for nothing so here we have rook
a to b1 you could also just trade bishop
characters here then queen captures here
and then we have the same game queen and
two rooks versus queen and two rooks
with magnus uh being up upon uh not
something maybe you wanna
uh you know i i it's basically self
torture so here rook a to b1 uh going
for the
dark square bishop here and magnus just
brings it back bishop to d4 we have rook
after c1 nicely aligning the rook with
the queen and rook ate the c8 and now of
course you know if this bishop moves
that magnus will happily give up the
queen for two rooks so queen to e4 and
now we have queen to d6 getting the
queen away from the c file king to g2
unpinning here now the f pawn can move
and now pawn to g6 magnus also creates
some breeding room for the king
we have rook to c2
now adding a defender to the f2 pawn but
also you can maybe double up on the c
file so bishop back to b6 and now we
have bishop to b3 offering a rook trade
on c2 which magnus goes for we have rook
captures bishop captures sorry not
bishop captures queen captures was
played in the game and now queen to d7
uh we have queen to e2 and now comes
rook the ca grabbing hold of the c file
uh neiman grabs hold of the d file
attacks the queen and queen the c6 with
check now uh and now uh how do you go
about this you could move the king sure
that is a possibility you could play f3
but neiman decides to go for the uh
opposite color bishop ending he plays
queen to f3 and magnus happily accepts
this with queen captures king captures
and now rook to c3 with check so magnus
is up upon but you know often uh in
practice that being up upon in a bishop
um of opposite color ending uh isn't
always the easiest thing to win but
still there are rooks in the game so
it's not a clean opposite color bishop
ending so king e2 we have g5 by magnus a
very important move to restrict the
movement of the f pawn and the h pawn
rook to f1 and now king to g7 we have
rook to d1 neiman repeats moves to see
how magnus will continue here and magnus
continues with the g4 further
restricting the movement of the f and
the h pawn
and now we have pawn to h3 here it's
already an incredibly difficult position
to hold but after h3 it is completely
unplayable
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find pretty much the only clean
way to win this for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
this congratulations on being a true
master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is a rook to f3 that's the only way to
play this we are attacking the f2 pawn
uh of course the bishop attacks it as
well this will come with check and uh
once you defend this with rook to f1
which was played in the game now comes
pawn to h5 and it seems like okay but
what has magnus really achieved here we
are defending the pawn uh white does not
have a move the only moves you can make
is move the bishop bishop d1 bishop b3
maybe a4 okay we can move the bishop
like this so it's not not a lot and we
can play king one king e2 king he won
king e2 that's basically the extent of
white's play uh for the uh for basically
the rest of the game so here h captures
on g4 magnus recaptures and now you have
to suffer the uncomfortable uh reality
that you have no moves so king to e1 and
now magnus can improve his position as
much as he likes uh you know he can
bring the king over to the c3 he can
bring the king over to like a1 if he
wants to for some reason now of course
he would be silly but he can do whatever
he wants so here pawn to a5
we have king to e2 now comes king to f6
now it's time to improve the position of
the king and start pushing these pawns
to victory king e1 uh only move king to
e5 and not only but i mean uh you could
also move the bishop so king to e2 we we
have to keep an eye on the f2 pawn we
have pawn to f5 and now king to e1 it is
very interesting to see how magnus will
actually win this king d6 we have king
e2 pawn to e5 now bishop to g8 now we
can also move our bishop this way
but it doesn't really do all that much
so bishop to d4 we have bishop to f7 and
now pawn to e4 we have bishop back to g8
king to e5 bishop to f7 and now pawn to
e3 and now there is no more time to wait
uh otherwise just rook captures on f2
will be
will be just winning so we have a
capture here and now rook captures an e3
with check you have to be careful not to
play rook captures on f1 because this
comes with check so rook captures an e3
the only way to play but uh you know not
a difficult one to spot king to f2 even
allowing some nasty discoveries for
magnus but luckily there aren't any so
yeah you can't really move the rook to
to win something so king to f6 a very
elegant solution by magnus now the
bishop is attacked and you have to be
very very careful where where you put it
even if you put it on b3 where it will
be defended we can just capture it and
it will be a discovered check from the
bishop so look at this now bishop to h5
magnus attacks it again king the g5
again what do you do if you move the
bishop let's say bishop to f7 we just
open up a discovery rookie 7 check and
pick up
that bishop so here uh neiman plays rook
to h1 this defends the bishop but it
also allows magnus to just cleanly end
the game rook to e7 check king to g2 now
rook back to e2 with check king to f1
only move rook to f2 with check now you
play king to e1 and now of course king
rook captures on a2 and he was in this
position on 54 that han smoking iman
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the problem is there's no defense
against rook to a1 check which will win
the rook so i mean if you move the
bishop to save the bishop then we pick
up the rook and if you move the rook uh
then let's say rook to f1 you play we
just play rook to a1 still and now you
lose
the rook and the bishop king e2 rook
captures on f1 king captures and king
captures an h1 leaving you completely
bishopless and uh other than that
there's really no point in in playing
much else for example if you play some
like rook to h4
okay you are defending your rook and
your bishop but uh i mean wha what what
is this uh we are not even going to
comment on this uh so yeah after rook
after sunday two and even resigns and
the magnus bounces back in the match
with a very nice positional win with the
black pieces in this weird variation of
the french defense uh so that's the even
meadow doesn't like it as you can see uh
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank alex
versilio francis air ricky amin
excellent subscriber and brandon ward
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the ftx crypto cup until it
finishes most likely
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day